so if you know you're getting feedback or you got noise in your room, please mute yourself.
Okay, so hello everybody. It is April, but I think it's the 74th day of January here in Minnesota
because we got a lot of snow this weekend. I think about 18 inches where we live.
So we're not here to talk about snow. We're here to talk about other things. We got a couple questions
emailed and then we will open it up for questions. So we're going to just talk about questions
and try to answer as many questions as we can. And I will say that if we could please, if you know,
if we don't have any questions that's fine, but if we could limit to one question a person, maybe two
that would be better because people are asking for that. Here was a question that came in and says,
when we start to clean up our diet and we start to eliminate processed foods and glue to the dairy and
soy and animal protein, would this cause withdrawal symptoms from MSGs, glutamates, etc.
It caused symptoms like sleepiness and sombre stomach headaches, blah, blah, blah.
Really, really good question because the answer to this is, yes, it can. So especially with
glutamate, so if all I are limited, if I eliminated even gluten, so gluten is the protein in wheat and
barley and rye, it's melted, that has nothing to do with glutamate. So if I eliminated gluten,
you could go on a, we could literally go for a withdrawal, but it typically, you know, about four or
five days and you're fine. I eliminated dairy, typically not much of a withdrawal, soy,
the only withdrawal that you could have some weird symptoms that you'd have is that
some possible hormone fluctuation because if you had been using a lot of soy,
and then you went off of it, soy is an estrogenetic substance and it can stimulate estrogens,
so that you can have some hormone fluctuation until things balance out. But when you talk about
eliminating glutamates, trying to eliminate glutamates in your diet and eliminating glutamine from animal
protein that breaks down into glutamate, you're talking about brain function, and yes, you could have
typically that's only going to last a week or so. So if you eliminate, if you clean out those
things and you're getting those things, these symptoms most later, I would think.
But let's talk a little bit about glutamate because it's an important thing to be careful of,
and try to eliminate. Okay, we're getting some feedback, so I am going to
mute everybody here. So glutamate is an important thing to eliminate. So remember what glutamate is,
glutamate is a neurotransmitter that your body makes. Your body makes it through a process of
breaking down glutamine. Glutamine is an amino acid that you consume. So glutamine is in protein.
So amino acids are little teeny molecules that make up proteins as they bind together. So different
proteins are just different combinations of different amino acids. Glutamate is one of those amino
acids. Now glutamate is not a bad guy, nor is glutamate a bad guy. It's simply access glutamate.
That's a bad guy for your brain. And access glutamate that can be a very bad guy for cancer,
because glutamate can feed cancer. Glutamate converts to glutamate, and back and forth glutamate will
convert to glutamate. Now glutamate is needed in your brain. It's a neurotransmitter. It's an
excitatory neurotransmitter. It's needed for you to wake up in the morning. You need glutamate.
It's needed for you to pay attention. That's where glutamate comes in. So glutamate is necessary.
It's excitatory. It raises your brain wave up to a beta wave. So that's where glutamates come in.
And access glutamate is where really where the problem is. I pulled up some studies here on this too.
Where do we have specific genetic defects? We can convert glutamate to glutamate quite quickly,
and that can cause problems. So if a person eats a lot of protein, so let's say we have a 12-year-old
little boy that has 80-D-80 HD. Well, his mechanism of 80-D-80 HD can be because he all he
likes to eat is chicken nuggets and pizza, which is a lot of animal protein, which is stimulating
glutamate production because he's getting all this glutamate from that protein, especially if he has
some some specific genetic defects that will convert even quicker. Well glutamate in the brain,
so this is a slide about what happens with glutamate receptors in the brain.
And all these M-H's here are specific, desired drug targets that they're trying to figure out
different ways to target to prevent this, because it's known that excess glutamate
causes brain cell death, excitotoxicity of brain cells right here, and eventually brain cell death.
So glutamate is being targeted as the major cause of Alzheimer's and even Parkinson's,
and certainly 80-D-80 HD type conditions, high levels of glutamate, and you end up with serious
problems. So we want cell death when we're talking about cancer cells, but that's not what this is
talking about. This is talking about brain cells. So high levels of glutamate over time is going to
cause brain cell death, increased rates of dementia, and this is what this study here is about
of why are there, you know, are dementia rates are just going through the roof at much earlier ages,
that the statistics are that within the next 10 years, the majority of people that are going to be
pre or in full dementia is going to be, they don't know how, as a country, we're going to be able
to care for everybody. So it's an important thing to look at. Question came in, can you measure
glutamate levels? No, you can't. Well, I should say, yes, there are neurotransmitter testing kits.
So you can measure the neurotransmitter levels. And on those neurotransmitter testing kits,
you will see glutamate has one of the things that's measured. The problem is that they're
urinary test kits. And if you test urinary glutamate levels, that is not, you cannot equate that to
the levels of glutamate in the brain. So to answer, yes, there are measurable ways to measure glutamate,
but no, they're not accurate for the measurement of neurotransmitters in the brain.
So we could do a neurotransmitter test. And it's a good test because you need neurotransmitters
throughout your body, not just your brain. But we're talking about the damaging effects of high
glutamate or problems with the temperament issues and anger or depression. And we're looking at
serotonin levels and dopamine levels, urinary neurotransmitter testing falls short. It's not an accurate
picture of what is going on in the brain. So you have to look at behavior. You have to look at
genetics. And then from that, you could extrapolate. So let's say a person has a
has a familial dispensation to to dementia, okay? My mother had dementia, my father had dementia,
aunt had dementia, my grandmother had dementia. Oh my gosh, she knows this is running in my family.
Well, we want to look at your genetics, your DAOA genes, your glute genes, and other glutamate
genes and glutamate genes that could increase a person's glutamate levels from consumed amino acid
glutamine, which if that is the case, then we'd say, boy, you have these defects in your glutamine
genes. You are going to produce excess glutamate. It would be who you to try to push out dementia
a little farther to decrease animal proteins go on a more plant-based diet. So what we have found
is that the glutamine in plant proteins doesn't have the exact same effects as the glutamine in
animal proteins. And I don't know why yet. I haven't found any studies that tell us why yet, but that's
just what we found clinically. So taking those people that let's say you don't even have a genetic test,
let's say we just know that you have dementia in the family, it may be a wise thing to do to go on a
more plant-based diet to decrease animal proteins, because you are going to decrease glutamate levels.
However, remember, if you're going to solely decrease glutamate levels by decreasing animal proteins,
but not decreasing dietary glutamate levels, well forget it. Well, where am I getting dietary
glutamate levels? Dietary glutamate levels are found in foods that are prepared foods.
Well, why would I have glutamates and prepared foods? Because the food industry is really smart and
they don't care about your health. If we're going to make a product and we want to sell a lot of it,
we'll load it up with glutamates. Glutamates are technically naturally, are natural substances,
so they can be listed as natural flavorings. That's when you see that on a label, most likely it has
glutamates in it. So glutamates are added to foods because glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter.
So it stimulates the glutamate receptors on your tongue. It is excitatory to the neurons in your
brain. Here it is excitatory. So excess glutamate causes excitotoxicity. That was a word coined by
Dr. Blalock, I believe, that excitotoxicity, that excitation of the glutamate receptors actually
causes cell death at the brain. That brain cell. So over time, constant up-regulation of glutamate in
the brain causes brain cell death. But what it does on a temporary basis, when you eat a Dorito with
four different types of glutamates in it, you taste it and you go, wow, this tastes good. I have to
get some more of these. These are delicious. Is it really good? No. It's just exciting glutamate
receptors. You think it tastes good because your brain is excited. Your brain is turned on.
So that's what's really important. Another question came in. Is there higher levels of glutamated red
meats than white meats? No, I don't believe so. It's the animal, it's the animal meats. And we haven't
seen the exact same reaction with glutamates in fish. So that's where we put a lot of you out, a
diet that contains very little red meat, very little white meat, but you could eat fish at eggs.
So no turkey and chicken, no red meat, which is beef and buffalo, no pork, no medicine,
but turkey and chicken eating a little bit, excuse me, but eating a little bit of fish tends to be okay.
Now, technically, if you look at a chart, you Google it, there is glutamated fish as well,
but it tends not to have the same exact same reaction. And we don't know exactly why.
So I would still try to limit those because we want to decrease our total glutamate output,
especially if we know your genetics already and we know you have defects on the glutamate genes,
you're going to be converting glutamate to glutamate more readily and you will have higher levels
of glutamate, the better what type of amino acid form of glutamate you're getting. So be careful of that.
So this is a slide about glutamate in the braid. Slide we talk about glutamate with cancer.
Here's an interesting article from a 2014 articles in frontiers of farbacology. And the article
talked about glutamates and a porter position. So what it does to a cancer stem cell,
and I cut off part of this slide because I thought I could make it an entire
talk at itself because what it does to affect iron with cancer cells is a whole other thing.
But just about how it increased the viability of cancer stem cells. So remember, cancer stem cells
are circulating tumor cells. So when you have even the smallest amount of cancer grown in your
body, even much less than what would be able to be detected with the PET skin. So let's say if I go,
I think I want to get a PET skin, pretend there's no toxicity in a PET skin because I don't know if
I have cancer because my mom had cancer and my uncle had cancer. So I want to get a PET skin too.
Then I go get a PET skin and there's zero cancer showing up on a PET skin. Does that mean I have no
cancer? The answer is no, it doesn't because remember 99% of the population have some cancer
growing in them. That's why when we do an IVG test on somebody that quote unquote does not have
cancer can still come back at a six because they do have some cancer. Their immune system is just
keeping it at bay and keeping it from ever becoming visible at a PET skin or a CT skin or palpable or
anything clinical or anything to even worry about. But you still have circulating tumor cells.
That's what's measured with the IVG. Circulated tumor cells are what are looking for a place to
set up home and raise a family. Their break off cells from a tumor that is circulating through the
body. That's what a cancer stem cell is. Well, this study shows that glutamate and cysteine
glutamate from glutamine, cysteine is another amino acids, increases the viability of cancer stem cell.
So it increases the life of cancer stem cells. So it increases the chance of that cancer stem cell
being able to set up home and raise a family someplace else from the primary side of cancer. That's
what's called metastasis. So just another reason to decrease animal proteins.
Question, what about the glutamates that are naturally occurring grains? Well, there are some
glutamates in other foods. I would not worry about those. You do need glutamate. It does serve
a good purpose. So we're not just villainizing glutamate here. We're villainizing excess glutamate.
And the truth is, again, we have so much excess glutamate in our diet that it's ridiculous to get
back to the old age-old argument. Well, I think the Bible says we're supposed to eat meat.
Well, really, yes, the Bible says you can eat meat. But how much do you think they ate in the old
testament? When you were supposed to bring the first fruits and the best of your first fruits for
sacrifice and of your flocks, and most people brought a dove. How much meat do you think they were
eating? You know, they were probably eating meat. Maybe, if you were wealthy once a week,
the average person in biblical time was probably eating meat maybe once a month or less.
So let's get this in perspective. We're eating meat three times a day, many times six times a day
in the American diet. So we got to put things in perspective a little bit. So glutamate can
increase cancer stem cell life. Gluters another article from Uncle Target in November 2014
talking about glutamate. Here's the first sentence of the figure here, a schematic overview of metabolic
pathways involving cancer biology. Cancer cells show it increase flux through glycolysis.
That's the warberg effect feeding cancer. So this is how cancer is fed. The pentose phosphate pathway
producing energy for the cancer at high glutamate consumption. So cancer is goblet of glutamate. So we
want to decrease glutamate levels. Another question, how do we know how to manage glutamate
if we have high level intake to have the right levels? Well, you can't, like I said, we can't really
measure it. So we have to be reasonable so that we're not going crazy here, right? And we're not
just constantly focusing on our diet. But this is where things like everything we've been talking
about for the last six months, doing the fasting mimicking diet can really help balance our back
our metabolism. So doing the time-restricted eating intermittent fasting, fasting a day a week,
those are the things that we're talking about. And decreasing, going back to glutamate and foods,
decreasing times that we're eating out. Or when you do eat out, stay away from
you know box restaurants that are going to have high glutamate levels in their foods.
Go to places where you can trust that they're that they're biodeorganic, you're getting organic foods
and you're not going to have glutamated your foods. I would trust even a Chipotle before I trust,
you know, some of the other restaurants that are out there. Again, I've shared this before. I went
into an Applebee's once and I told the waitress, I said, can you go ask the cook what in your menu
doesn't have glutamate? Because I'm really, really allergic to glutamate. It was just a test.
So she comes back after about 10 minutes. She said, the chef said that every single thing on our menu
has glutamate. So where does Applebee's buy their food? They buy it from major restaurant
but supplyhouses where most restaurants buy their food. And this is what you're going to get at any
of the chain restaurants, really. So you go into restaurants that are more hometown,
mom, pop places that you know the order can develop a relationship with them and know where they're
sourcing their food. Look at where you're sourcing your food. Don't buy things that say natural and
artificial flavorings on it unless it says in there no glutamates are in the food. So that's how
you could reduce the levels. And then again, like I said, decrease your animal meat consumption.
So we're not talking about being crazy and we're not talking at all about I'm not going to have any
more glutamate in my body. If you did, you die. So that's not the purpose either where we do see
and try to bring things into balance. So because right now we are out of balance and that's what can
be a major fuel source for our cancer. It can be a major cause of our kids ADD ADHD issues, behavioral
issues, hormonal imbalance. And it is the number one cause for dementia. So we don't want any of those
things. So we need to work on those. All right. So I'm going to open up for questions. But we did
have another question that came in about iodide levels and breast cancer. So different topic,
iodide levels and breast cancer. So we can say iodide levels with any cancer really but mainly
breast cancer are most the articles about iodide. So we want iodide levels. We, or let's say
rephrase that. We don't want our iodide levels to be low. So iodide levels are being higher,
higher than normal. I think normal iodide levels on saliva or urine test is 100 to 300.
And really with somebody with cancer, we'd really want them maybe 200 to 600-ish. That's what I like
to see for iodide levels. And those are measurable. And those are accurate. So it's a good idea to get
those measured. The test is, I don't know, 80 bucks to do an iodide test. It's pretty simple and
pretty easy. And we can send you out a kit if you're interested in looking at that. If you have higher
iodide levels of 1,000, 2,000, that's not necessarily a bad thing. It can be protective to your thyroid as
well. The only thing that I want to ask is what is your source of iodide? Most supplements out there,
people that are supplemented iodide are using a legal solution or another capsule supplement that
is using potassium iodide. I'm not a big fan of potassium iodide because that's not a natural source
of iodide. So I'd rather have you get a kelp-based source of iodide, not a potassium iodide synthetic
source. That's the only thing about that. So we should measure your iodide levels if you have
interest in that. Make sure you contact the office. All right. I am going to unmute everybody and
open that up for questions that it could be a totally different subject matter. So
whoever wants to pipe it. This is Christina. I do have a question for you.
You made the homeopathic gadolinium solution for me. I was just wondering if I should use it
until the bottle is gone or if I should use it for a set amount of time.
You could use it until the bottle is gone. Are you having any symptoms that you feel like are related
to the gadolinium? Initially, after I had the contrast, I had some bladder irritation for about 48 hours
and I just increased my water intake and did some vegetable juicing and it seemed to clear
with that. So since then, no, I haven't had any symptoms. Okay, good. So for those who might not
understand what she's speaking about gadolinium is used in a contrast medium die for MRIs. That's
very common. And it's generally thought that it's safe. The problem is that it is an element of the
periodic table and there is no studies on whether it's safe and there are numerous, numerous reports
of people having very severe toxicity reactions from gadolinium. So Chuck Doris is probably the most
notorious case of this. His wife, everybody knows who Chuck Doris is. His wife had a severe
gadolinium toxicity reaction. There is a great informational website about gadolinium toxicity
few years ago. There was informational website put up about that by some of the victims of that.
Trying to raise awareness. There has been numerous peer-reviewed research articles showing that it
can be very toxic. Now they have wardings on it. What good are wardings? Because they never tell
any patients about it. If you've ever had an MRI, did you remember them saying, well, we're usually
gadolinium and that can be a very toxic substance. So you should make sure you tell us if you have any
toxic reactions because we better use some key lady substance to get that out of you and we need to
ward you about this. Probably not. So it is, but it, but besides the most severe reactions that
people that will tie back to that and do their own research and figure out that they just got
giant toxicity issue with gadolinium, there's more people with just minor things. So they just don't
feel well after that. The problem is, I believe that it could cause a lot of people to tumble down
who's getting an MRI in the first place? People that maybe are not completely well and then they're
getting the toxicity from a contrast die. That's just not wise. The problem is, is that the radiologists
and the radiology community is kind of pickle because without the die, they just can't see
the contrast die is to give a contrast in an imaging study so that they can see the difference
between different tissue types. So without it, they lose a lot of that ability to see that.
Well, then you get to, well, maybe we should do some different, you know, types of imaging or studies.
So it's, it is a catch 22 that's out there. If you, if you have compromised detox pathways,
that's going to be worse. It is not, I have not seen any studies showing which pathway
gadolinium detoxifies through. Most likely it's the PUN1 pathway, but I'm not for sure because most,
a lot of heavy metals detoxify through the PUN1 pathway. So if we had somebody's genetics and we could
look at, wow, you have a lot of PUN1 defects. Maybe you should not get the contrast die or just skip
the MRI all together. That would probably be our best bet as far as trying to look at it free
doing the MRI contrast and prevent any deal. But yes, what Christine is talking about is we do have
a whole wheel path for gadolinium. So a whole wheel path helps detoxify a substance very gently.
If someone is very tox, or has a very toxic reaction to gadolinium, then we probably have to go
a little bit stronger than a whole wheel path and use a stronger key later. So those are, there's some
different keylators that we use and have different strikes, quote unquote, pull it out. So
hopefully that helps. Now there's another, it's probably leaded to another question is that
the radiation from, you don't get radiation from an MRI, but you get radiation from a PET scan and
we have a whole wheel path for the radiation toxicity to help pull that out on that helps as well.
So none of these things are perfect. Another question came in about the question that
that Mike posted on the Facebook page about the hydrogen peroxide therapy. So I forgot to add
that to the slide presentation. Sorry about that, Mike. But if you guys did get a chance to look at that,
please look at his question and I'll try to remember to put a maybe make a presentation and put
it a slide presentation about it. But there are some people that are using hydrogen peroxide therapy
as a therapy for cancer. I'm not a big advocate for it. We do have hydrogen peroxide on the shelf
here and we test people for it on a regular basis. The only people that it tends to come up with
it to use hydrogen peroxide as a therapy are people with chronic blood. Now I can understand
the mechanism how hydrogen peroxide could be beneficial for a chronic biotoxin because the
oxidizing agent, because that's what hydrogen peroxide is, is an oxidizing agent, could be oxidizing
to a bacteria, you know, it killed a bacteria. The problem with an oxidizing agent is it's oxidizing
to our cells and it could cause cancer. So that's what we're trying to decrease in our body is all
the oxidizing agents, chemical toxicity, some things are oxidizing agents. That's why, you know,
pesticides and everything, all these things can oxidize the cell membranes, damage our cell membranes,
and decrease the viability of cells and increase cancer. So there's thousands of studies that
relate to that. So I just don't see hydro peroxide as a real viable solution for cancer. So I
could get more into that presentation. Back to the iodine is for table salt if we're going to use
limited amounts, is there something better than another like the sea salt and the Himalayan salt is
that? So you'd want, so for salt, if you're using salt, I would not be using any white salt.
If people go, whoa, I want the white salt because it's iodide, it's got iodide, I want to have low iodide
levels stuck with thyroid. Well, white salt is horrible for you and the iodide it is potassium iodide.
So that's not the right source of iodide either. So you're much better off using a sea salt
or a Himalayan salt or, you know, a Hawaiian black salt and there's many different salts on the
market that have minerals in it. That's the benefit of those salts. They have other minerals in it.
I would not say that that's not, that should be your source of iodine though. So your
iodide should be, if you're getting a natural source of iodide, should be a kelp-based iodine
is typically your going to be your best source of iodine. And then what do you think of the Himalayan
salt lamps? Because I hear that they have like amazing benefits and other people say it's just a big
sham. Well, I think there's probably a mixture of both of those things. I think there's benefits
to them, but I don't think there's amazing as they say they are. That's just leaving at that. I
don't think it's going to secure, you know, your baldness and, you know, and everything that they
claim that they are. So it's just not as illogically possible when you really think about it. So would
you hear all these benefits from some different products and you at least my iodide goes,
how does that actually work metabolically? That doesn't work that way. So you know, that's where you
have to be. You just got to think through some of these things. I could see there's benefit. It's
you know, you know, doing some things, but not what they say. Any other questions?
Well, I guess since no one else is asking, as I've been eating healthier, I've been losing weight
and actually losing too much weight and also muscle mass. So I know with the muscle, I need to,
you know, try to focus on more protein and exercise, but should I be concerned about
not really having any fat on my body? Like, I'm probably
considered underweight and people look at me and think I'm, you know, like maybe anorexic, but
you know, I don't know if I should purposely eat something to try to get fat.
Okay, so good question. So if we feel like we're losing weight and boy, maybe a little
losing a little bit too much weight and I don't have the same muscle tone that I used to,
if you eat a whole bunch of protein, you're not going to increase muscle tone. You only increase
muscle tone by using the muscle. So the only way to increase muscle tone is to, is to start
lifting weights or start doing some, it doesn't have to be weights, but some exercise that's
stimulating muscle growth. So just because muscles are made of protein, do not take the
flight leap that if I eat more protein, I'll have more muscles on my bones. It doesn't work that way.
Okay, carbohydrates will break down and help make muscle so will fats. So I'm not saying you
should eat carbohydrates either, but if don't just equate that as a one-to-one measurement that if
I need muscles, muscles are protein. So I better eat some animal muscles or something that's
going to be protein for help me to build muscle. The only way for you to build muscle tone is to
call for more muscles. And the way you call for more muscles is you utilize that muscle.
So the more you do a biceps curl, the more your brain goes, whoa, we need to add more muscle there
because this, this motion is called for by the, by the person. So we need to lay down more muscle
there. So you need to do an exercise program that you're going to build muscle or increase tone.
So you have to have calories in your body to be able to do that because if you are undercalorieed
throughout the entire day. So we talk about fasting mimicking diet. We're really undercalorie
ourselves, but only for a window of five days. And then you go back to your diet again that you
should have ample calories in order to build muscle and to stay at your weight.
Same day with with time restricted eating or intermittent fasting, it doesn't mean that you're
undercalorie yourself for the entire day. And that's your purpose is to lose weight. So if a
person is overweight and their purpose is to lose weight, then during that time restricted eating
that during their feed time, they could reduce their calories and they're going to lose weight.
But in your time restricted eating, if you're not trying to lose weight during your feeding time
you need to consume the calories that you need to consume to do the things that you need to do which
is means to maintain your weight and to build muscle. Quite honestly, when you're trying to build muscle,
it doesn't make any difference what form the calories you're taking it in, whether it's carbohydrates,
whether it's fats or whether it's protein. But you will not build muscle unless you exercise. But if
you start an exercise procedure where you're going to get some 10 pound weights and you're going to
google how to build a muscle tone and you're going to get an exercise chart where you're going to do
you know, 10 overhead pushes and laying out on your on your back and do 10 pushes straight up and
you're going to do 25 curls and you're going to so you lay out a program for yourself, whatever
you create, then you are going to be sore. Yeah, but besides being sore, you're going to call
for your body to make more muscle and then it will pull it in from whatever macro nutrients
you're consuming throughout the day. What would you say the reverse is true because I feel like I lost
the muscle mass from reducing like my intake of animal protein. But I don't think I did any less
exercise, but I got I really lost a lot of muscle. I don't think you there's any studies that will
show that you will lose muscle by the decrease of animal proteins. And I go you know the simplest
way to get people to understand that is to say is to say look at as look at a gorilla they all they
eat is plant protein and look at how strongly they are. There is case after case of bodybuilders
that are vegans. So it's not about consuming the animal protein that is going to you could go
eat a whole bunch animal protein you're not going to increase muscle mass. But if you consume a lot
of calories and you exercise you'll you'll build up that muscle mass. Okay. Just you have to increase
the calories because if you're going to exercise your body calories right. So then you're going to have a
higher caloric intake need. So make sure you're increasing your your caloric intake need. And that's
where you want to help put on weight. Another perfect example is my horse. Okay. My horse does not eat
any animal proteins, but he's all muscle. And if we in my horse my wife's horse is old. She's a 30-year-old
horse and he's he's getting up there at age and he doesn't have very good teeth and he doesn't he doesn't
chew the hay very well. He doesn't get the nutritive value of the hay. He can't out of the grass. But in the
winter if we don't take him in every every day and grade him he will lose weight and he's going to die.
But we've kept him alive for another last three years by giving him some grade every day.
Now grade has zero animal protein, right? But his body will convert your body will convert
macro nutrients. Now the macro nutrients are divided as carbohydrates, fats, or protein. So whatever
macro nutrients that you consume, if you act like a horse and you walk around all day and you run
around and you call for that need for muscle you will build muscle. But you have to have enough of
those macro nutrients on a given day to supply those energy needs too. Dr. Connors, this is Deb.
The volume of that we have to eat for vegetables to get the calories that you're just saying
for muscle building. I'm sorry I'm practically incapable of ingesting all that.
You're right. So that's where you may have to. So if a person is like I'm in weight loss here and I
can't keep my weight up that's where you may have to go to grades. I'm doing that maintaining but I'm
still like other person still considered demands added according to other people are kind of worried
about me. But if you're going to eat a protein source, where are you getting your proteins from?
Well, I'm eating the vegetarian diet you put me on. Yeah. So there is some vegetarian sources of
protein, right? I'm doing, yeah, I'm not losing anymore, but it's just that people who work like
she said people are looking like anorexic. So if you're maintaining and you're not
truly underweight but comparatively you've lost a lot of weight since you know you spent maybe
I'm not saying just for you Deb but for a lot of people spend a good portion of their 40 years of
life have been you know 30 pounds overweight and that has been quote unquote normal for them and
now they're back in a weight that they look very initiated compared to the way they're used to eat.
We're not talking about a person who's losing two pounds a week and can't seem to stop losing two
pounds a week. But if your weight has leveled off then I would say maintain it. Now what I think
Sharon said is that I can't seem to gain my muscle mass. So if you're going to start exercise to
try to gain muscle mass you're going to burn through more calories so you're going to have to add calories
to your diet. And if you're like I'm already eating a lot of food and I can don't know if I can
add any more calories then you're going to have to look at more concentrated sources.
Yeah. Increase your fat you can use that's why we carry that protein side that chocolate and
vanilla protein that's a all vegan based protein so that's a good protein. So there's ways to do
it depending on what you're trying to do. Okay thank you. All right well we probably should cut off
because we're at about 50 minutes on this call. So make sure you email your questions in.
And sorry Mike about that. I had your proximate question I forgot about that. So I'll get to that.
And it also asks your questions on Facebook obviously so we want to be able to get to those
24-7 on that. Thank you guys. Hopefully it'll warm up here in Minnesota and hopefully it's a lot
warmer where you are. Head we will see you next week. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Have a good week. Thank you.